[Music]
we're back we're back
holy [ __ ] talking about whatever
whatever [ __ ] safe I forgot how
[ __ ] scared this sound sorry what the
look is
I am the way that what's going on what
the [ __ ] oh my god
I'm walking so [ __ ] slow okay okay
the thing is look um the tiniest [ __ ]
movement if something happens when I try
to turn around I'll just end up walking
back oh [ __ ] I forgot about the madness
I picked up the [ __ ] land and what's
follow I need oil a trench let's not
seen in darkest
oh [ __ ]
there ah that's doesn't just careful
moments with mouth
this looks like
Jesus [ __ ] penis
get his humble Kampf corners I got this
work last night
here find some oil what the [ __ ] is that
no no no no no don't lose it where did
it go
break it why did I break it
did it help bro let's check in here for
blood
so [ __ ] hard to see it's so [ __ ]
dark Jesus penis does actually pick up
the no don't read it now let's go go up
the pocket I don't think so
[Music]
stop turning you have a seat big though
got a sneak peek
Oh most repulsive almost impossible
bucket bucket oh no fix out ah bucket
[Music]
oh I don't got that matter
that's it safe oh it's alerts alerts
alerts oh there they'll come here
[Music]
done
we mean all the [ __ ] shut up trying
what's sticking ticking is not good
I'm not good when huh oh please be
reasonable
you don't have to do this
charge no I can't breed no no wait I do
the sound effects nothing made that
mistake too many [ __ ] things
Indonesia all right you see my love and
no I'm not someone complain I read to so
[ __ ] you I'm not talented as my lover
are c I'm strong faster than you it's
from this bad style but I'm certainly my
love is true were to wear decided really
has a more true
okay do not do not my scars tell you so
I will continue to cut myself as long as
it pleases you I would even killed
mesial be spare whatever if you wish I
know you say you like it but he's
hurting you I will trick him to consume
bromide bromide and long for just seeing
I will I will just just ask for help how
was there was an Opel miss though and
I'm sorry about that I mean walking here
you [ __ ] Jesus Christ
oh [ __ ] do I know
Oh should we help okay let's go
ah that's gross
oh sweet my boy holy [ __ ] we're bad
person I guess it had to be done
difficult to animate I guess enemy
am i all [ __ ] spiders [ __ ] great
ah [ __ ]
which way it's [ __ ] after me I bet
it's [ __ ] after me ah I don't want to
find out what it is I don't wanna fight
I am oh oh it's right by it sounds like
it's my talking behind me holy [ __ ] oh
just [ __ ] bud yes I get Ron yes
[ __ ] Ron yes [ __ ] you dead end
woo I'm [ __ ] I don't wanna know what's
after be don't look left nothing there
okay okay
yes okay I've got it
okay I [ __ ] did it I like here I like
it
okay good go slowly near okay don't open
it fastest of it why if there was
someone in there okay we'll get going on
here newspaper article 19 of March 1855
traveler blah blah
many Papa Paris island had to gather
last night to enjoy the performance of
violin for - so Marlo debonair it was to
be the grand premiere of several new
arrangement of songs by fellow composer
georges bizet but the evening took
unexpected turn
young malo the big knee turned out
visibly intoxicated his violin cried as
the bow was jerked across the strings
Geritol the audience seemed forgiving at
first but started to boo the man off
stage as he whatever the song loved us
whatever distress and they got the best
of the young young young yeah whatever
[ __ ] pronunciation I see through his
bow into the audience and final collapse
but Marcel just seen floor Bell who is
according to rumors romantically
involved with a Monsieur the mean the
quite amused by the event I had two of
her friends by City Hall and Allah I see
em I see em whatever carry him off the
stage
the evening was saved by other musicians
at the conservatory who was able to
perform and a most delightful improbable
Baba okay that was [ __ ] useful oh how
sweet
so let's mark this
oh you sure Oh do
I mean I don't have any boxes I don't
have [ __ ] you do have alcohol actually
do don't know alcohol is that there is
nothing oh yeah see what the lady has to
say I can guess congratulations
recovering it oh so excited for you I do
hope you managed to save a few for yay
it was a friend and a colleague of my
father oops
friendly sellers a real home but are you
sure please go on
we are just getting started alright
don't open those great players do
whatever
don't like the sound of this don't like
the sound of this this looks like the
prison in amnesia
oh that's looks comfortable freakin
royal style the gloomy space downstairs
became a playground I'm a serious place
were just needing to discover with their
friends all right
what I didn't realize in amnesia was
that the small text was the loading
textbook whoa what the was describing
the danya's childhood or whatever I
didn't get that that's probably you
should be looking for some divine
inspiration time to delve into your
spiritual side what you see is the man
begging immersing or dipping
you